in pakistan sin province farmers say
they're facing a threat to their future
the biggest problem here is water our
birds and animals are suffering because
there is absolutely no water i appeal to
the government to supply us with water
summer in parts of south asia arrived
early this year
march was the hottest in a century in
the region while april broke several
records
in sindh farmers growing lemons chiles
falca
say their crops have been damaged
because of a shortage of water
we get water from the irrigation
department every other month but last
month some farmers didn't get enough and
their crops dried up
blame global warming for a rising number
of floods in the north of pakistan and
drought in the south
they say changing weather patterns are
putting millions of people at risk of
famine
[Music]
the south of punjab and all of sindh
have been hit by extreme water shortage
the situation is so bad that people
don't even have water to drink why our
perennial river system has no water
rivers have little water because of lack
of rain
pakistan has been spending up to 14
billion dollars a year to adapt to the
changing environment
farmers in sins say it's not happening
quickly enough
victoria gaitambi al jazeera